Morning, Chester. Morning, Karine. Morning, Danny.
Hi, good morning.
Good morning, folks.
What are you all doing?
Good morning, everyone.
The money.
Doing good, thank you.
That's great.
Long time, no see. We've been meeting after one month.
How's everything going?
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah, everything's everything's good.
Blake it.
All right.
Just give me a moment.
Okay, so thank you so much, Danny and Chester, for joining this call. So let's quickly jump on to the agenda and starting with Ray, how things are moving with him.
I'll let Danny speak.
Danny, you are on mute.
You're still muted.
You went on mute again.
You're on mute again, Danny.
Hoh.
Something is all.
It's on here. Yep, now it's better.
There you go.
Sorry about that. I said his utilization went up, so he's at 82%, which is past our goal of 80, so everything's going good.
That's great. And in terms of the improvement points, Chester, that you mentioned regarding he is describing the tickets that he's entering, they are specifically specified as for the role. So Ray is working on it and I think he has completely worked on that piece and it has been taken.
Hoh.
Yeah.
Yep, that's right. So, Danny, when you mentioned about the utilization piece of 82%, as per our calculation, I will certainly show the numbers when we go through the presentation deck. But before that, I see we have Keith with us. Hey, Keith, how are you doing?
Mhm.
Okay.
If.
I'm good buddy, how are you?
Big Reid.
Hey, Jester, hey Danny, hey Karine.
Hey, hey Keith.
Hey, hey.
So, let me just give you a quick intro. So, Keith is one of the senior technical team leads working with IT by design, so he will be helping me with the MSP Corp. So, yeah, he'll be a frequent visitor on these service calls in the near future.
Sounds good, welcome.
Thank you.
Kip.
Thank you. Looking forward to work with you guys.
Now we can play.
Mackless.
Before I jump into the presentation deck, anything else, Jester, Denny, you want to share?
Nope.
Yep.
Shall we bring up my screen?
Let me know if you're able to see it.
Yep.
Thank you. This is our monthly business review and reiteration is May 1st till May 29th. Starting with our agenda items for today, they remain same. We will have check-in, highlights of the account, action tracker, performance analysis, points of the customer, pay forward and then recap.
We have covered this slide already.
Here we have the discussion points from our previous Connect where race over performance and transition under Dennis leadership were reviewed positively. We focused on the CSAT transitions that have been taken care. And thank you so much, Danny, for sharing the CSAT survey for Ray. We appreciate it.
And we discussed with Ray regarding the charge codes when he's working on the tickets. So this is something that he has fixed already. So yeah, we are in good heads.
One.
Any questions so far?
No.
Nope.
Thank you.
Okay, this is the access to the reporting piece, which is still being considered. So yeah, let me know, Danny, once we are there so that we would have access to the BrightGauge or internal reporting tool so that we can have real-time access of race data.
Okay, are we waiting, Chester, are we waiting till we get on boarded to the new system or are we talking about the current one?
Um, we're waiting until we get to the new system.
Okay, perfect. Makes sense.
Okay.
Sorry, just one more thing about the charge codes. When he's entering charge codes, we just need a little bit of detail on what that charge code was used for, right? You know, if it's a...
Kour.
Training and assistance, just put a little bit about what the training was about, right? Because, you know, I was looking last week, he's got three hours of training and assistance, but there's no details on what those are.
Okay.
I got it.
Makes sense.
Sure, I'll make sure that he will put that as well.
Thank you.
You like him?
Yeah, we were the KPIs that we discussed, so...
I'll quickly move to performance analysis. This is the utilization piece for Ray. And as per the calculation that we have internally, although it is less than what you have at your end, but it's still 75% with us, which is still a good number. And so I have considered.
Mhm.
Mm-hmm.
May 8th, which was a holiday, which is why we could see a dip in his utilization third week of May. However, he was able to maintain 75 plus in the rest of the weeks for the month of May.
Yeah.
Yep.
Any questions there?
No.
Thank you.
Next we have is the tickets resolved. So Ray has closed 181 tickets in total. So throughout the month, he worked on Office 365 cases, SharePoint, server support, and other alerts and escalation from different team members. The required target he had is like 8 tickets per day. So he has surpassed them every week.
Mhm.
So as we can see, the target for May 8th was 32. He was able to close 36 tickets there because 18 was enough. And rest of the weeks, we can see the numbers are purpassing the required targets.
Cool.
Hoh.
And Pre had been vocal in terms of asking for more work, because we also observed, and Danny, we had a chat on that as well. I think third week of May and towards the end, we observed a slight dip in the ticket inflow. So please utilize Pre in.
internal projects, any reporting or wherever you feel that he could be utilized because when he's done with the tickets, I have advised him to reach out to you so that he can be utilized for anything and everything that can be that can add value to your site.
Sounds good.
Okay.
Right, way forward. So AZ104 certification is completed by Ray. So that's that. And strong focus on the guide infrastructure. Ray is working on it already. Utilization has got better and accurate time capture and agreement alignment. So this is something that we have coached Ray already.
Mhm.
I think he's going for his SC300, right?
Yes, he is preparing for SC300, yes.
Rick.
All right, this is Bill 80 so I think the team is registered already. I can skip this one.
This starting to be a slide, that is it.
Any other questions, Danny Chester?
Nope, I'm good.
Thank you.
No, nothing else on my side.
Right, Karine, anything you want to add?
No, I'm sorry. No, just waiting for a few suitable candidate.
Yep, yep, I saw your email and uh, yep, we're working on it.
Okay, thank you very much.
Thank you.
You're welcome, Sarbjeet.
Excellent.
You have, you are a neutral.
No, all good.
Thank you.
You're welcome, Keith.
Sarbjeet on mute doesn't happen very often, right? It was shocking for me too, but yeah, I'm good, really.
Yeah.
Yep, yep.
Unfortunately, my headphone gone has gone faulty.
Yeah.
So, Keith, do you do you work in the same office as OK? Alright, good, good to know.
Right, thank you.
Yes, same office, correct.
Mm.
Yeah.
All right.
Right, I guess this is it I have for today. Our next meeting is scheduled for 7th of July. Not established, 14th of July. Until then, please take care of yourself. And before we call it off, I believe 1st of July is a holiday.
at MSP Corp. So I just wanted to confirm if you are comfortable, Ray, taking this off or you want him to be available as rest of the team would not be on shift.
I don't remember if July 1st is not a U.S. holiday, right? I think it's only Canadian.
Yes, so yeah, July 1st is Canada holiday and July 3rd is US Independence Day. So we are observing 3rd of July, but you know, in case you want to swap, we can also do that.
I don't know the day.
Uh.
Yeah, because if it's, I have to check if it's a US holiday, if it's not a US holiday, then we'll need Ray.
to cover.
Uh...
Kour.
The.
It looks like it's only Canada, I think, and then U.S. gets Fourth of July, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Or for July, yeah.
Yep, we are getting it on 3rd because 4th is Saturday, so we are off 1:30.
Okay.
Yeah, so, and that's the case, yeah, we'll need him to to cover to be around for July 1st.
All right, I can make this. It'll be done.
Yeah.
OKOK. Thank you.
Okay, thank you so much.
You're welcome.
Alrighty. Well, thank you so much for your time. We'll see you next month. Until then, take care and have a good one.
Right.
Pre.
All right. Have a great day. Thank you. See you in a month. Bye.
Thank you. Bye-bye. Bye.
Thank you, everyone. Take care. Bye.
Bye. Thank you. Thank you, everyone.